anyways yeah I would say feminists girls
that like are super only fans club like
that sort of thing and
um
whales number one is whales do you know
why they hate you like do you do you
because I my perception like the way I
feel about it is that they hate you
because you're saying stuff there's
truth to it if there wasn't truth to
what you were saying they wouldn't hate
you they would just be like oh who cares
yeah there's truth to it and also it
makes them reflect on their own choices
so now if you're talking about how
female promiscuity is not empowering and
they've been promiscuous and they bought
the story that that was somehow
empowering they're listening to you and
they're like we gotta shut her up see
and here's the thing a lot of times we
have this narrative like oh they bought
the story when they're young I don't
really believe that I think deep down on
an innate level we all know because
what's the first thing that girls call
each other when we're mad you're a hoe
why are you saying that if it's a good
thing I feel like sometimes that's a
cop-out that women use well they'll be
like oh I bought it and I'm like did you
did so you don't think that women bought
the story then why did they do it if
they didn't buy the story they just
wanted no consequences and like honestly
there really aren't a like even I mean
you could you're a generation older but
I asked my mom I'm like do the hoes get
married too she said yeah so at the end
of the day there's really not a lot of
consequences for any of it see I think
they have to have bought the story to an
extent because there's too many of them
that aren't comfortable being
promiscuous like they'll do it but they
go home they're miserable they cry about
it they call their friends they're mad
yeah they're mad the guy didn't call
them back they're expecting that guy to
behave like a boyfriend when it was
really clearly just to hook up so
they're so upset about it that they're
then trying to map out with their friend
on the phone like why doesn't he like me
because it's like they bought the story
that somehow they were going to be
promiscuous and it was going to feel
good and they were going to get what
they wanted or something beneficial for
them out of that situation and they
don't they're all miserable I think like
there's a hesitance to point out that a
lot of women who followed feminist
advice they're just so unhappy they
don't reflect like they're promiscuous
but unhappy they're on birth control
unhappy they're climbing the corporate
ladder unhappy why why no
self-reflection in the process do you
think
um I I just kind of have a different
view on it I just I just think they
liked the party life I just think it was
fun you know what I mean like okay maybe
how many girls do you really know that
are really climbing the corporate ladder
I mean you maybe you think you lived in
New York right maybe you knew more of
them but most girls that I know just
have average jobs and most girls in
general have average jobs they're not
climbing anything I mean I know a lot of
girls that are trying that are trying to
compete with men like in the cities and
I grew up with a lot of them that were
like I want to be the manager I want to
be the CEO I want to be like that's
that's a sign that I've been successful
in life and they they four went having
children for a really long time in order
to do that so I think they exist and
they're you know this is just I'm just
saying by and large the average salary
is like 35
000 a year for women so like by and
large women aren't climbing the
corporate ladder like there are some
right maybe like 10 15 but I would say
like by and large it's more just like it
was fun so they want to have fun yeah so
you you believe that women modern women
are deriving enjoyment from that Pro
promiscuity structure they're they're
you believe they're not unhappy no I
think they're unhappy like how do I put
it when the consequences happen so like
when they sleep with a bunch of people
and then like everyone finds out and
they're like oh [__] you know now but do
I think like to start yeah they're
having fun and then you know life
catches up to you it's kind of like you
eat 10 cheeseburgers every time you eat
the cheeseburger it's fun you're happy
but then you're 300 pounds
Rebecca yeah um so that's how I see it
yeah see I don't think they're having
fun I think they're programmed little
robots I think they're largely miserable
and I think they they can't change
because they don't they've been told
that that's what they should be doing
it's crazy though you look at like
college girls coming out today some of
these body counts how you coming out of
college 15 20 people
telling me I mean did you study
girlfriend did you do what did you do
like I don't understand where that kind
of time comes from honestly oh my God no
oh my gosh the girl on my show the one
who I was like okay this is I'm gonna
tell you this story okay I'm sorry I'm
all over the place she may get the names
away look at look at Amy and and she
comes on my show and she's she okay I
did we're talking a show about body
count right how many bodies too many
body questions like that I don't usually
the only time I ask people their body
count is when I say is body count
important and they say no and then I say
then what's your body count but the
point isn't to get their body count the
point is to show it's important right
because otherwise everyone would just be
like this you know so um on this show as
a joke I was like what's he has his body
count and I said haha you don't have to
say it's okay like I was kidding she's
all this Pro sex girl so she's like oh
I'll say it to get rid of the stigma are
you sure she says yes okay go ahead go
ahead this girl threatens to sue me
because she said her body count on live
that's ridiculous why did you say say it
so litigious people oh my God sex
positive that's another that's a word
that just popped into my head I don't do
you watch any of this like The
Bachelorette or any of that stuff you
watch any of those shows oh my gosh they
used to my team used to watch it in
college but I would get so bored and
then I would just give my opinion I like
no imagine watching The Bachelorette
with me giving my opinions
they stopped inviting me I said they're
like they're like probably like do don't
care I mean like if you think it's
stupid
um but I actually I started watching the
Recaps and I liked those better there's
like so this is a channel called
Bachelor fan takes so sometimes I'll
watch the Recaps of season so it's
interesting to watch because if you
especially if you're in this area and
you're doing this kind of content it's
interesting to watch first of all if you
go to older episodes you can see like
how much male female Dynamics have
changed even in terms of what's
presented to the public in the last like
15 years much more traditional like if
you looked at you know some of the First
episodes versus what you see now but
there was a girl on it recently a couple
of seasons ago and she was sex positive
she actually showed up and the first
thing that she did was pull out a dildo
Katie Katie Thurston and she was like
and these women are like kind of
horrified that guys would care about
body count like the guys get to the end
and they say like hey if you're sleeping
with a bunch of girls I can't do this
like you're already you're supposed to
be in love with me and the girls are
like this is outrageous and the audience
loves what the girls are saying they
love it because they're like yeah girl
power in the meantime and they're like
if he really loves you and you're saying
you love him you shouldn't be able to go
into the next room and sleep with
somebody else honey something's broken
inside oh my oh you're talking about
Hannah brown or whatever oh yes when she
slept with the yeah and like what guy
wants to mirror producer
you want to marry a girl that's proposed
to a girl that slept with another dude
three days before three days before
would you sign up for that Delhi you
going down the aisle or no no
but seriously how do you even how do you
I mean I don't understand what's so
broken see what bothers me is I feel
like there's something broken in women
because and I keep going back to like
it's not natural for us to behave this
way I don't feel like it's natural for
women to behave this way and like what
is broken that you can't even understand
now that a guy cares that three days ago
you're sleeping with someone else and
now you're in his bed that's nasty yeah
I I do feel like hypergamy is natural
like women like like monkey branching
and dating up that's been I went to an
art museum and there's paintings of
girls being hypergamous
red pill lens on an on a museum walk
yeah yeah Ally took me she took a new
Museum and she was showing me I'm like
oh my gosh
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible